It's great to welcome to the program today,
Mara Vist and Doll, who's the former China
correspondent for science and also author
of The Scientist and the Spy A True Story
of China, the FBI and Industrial Espionage.
So great to talk to you today, Mara.
Thanks again for having me on the show.
So let's start with industrial espionage.
Many people not familiar with this or may
have an idea of what it means.
Donald Trump notably talking about it typically
in reference to China.
China treating us unfairly, China stealing
intellectual property.
What's the big picture of industrial espionage?
Is it typically involving in intellectual
property?
What are the sort of different types that
maybe exist?
So going after industrial espionage from China
has been a huge priority of the Trump administration.
It is one of the ostensible justifications
for the trade war that he started with China.
But the focus on it actually goes back over
a decade to the Obama administration.
The FBI made fighting industrial espionage
a top priority and started taking on investigations
involving technologies like the whitener,
Oreo cookies, wind turbines and even genetically
modified corn, which is at the heart of my
book.
So on that note, I mean, so if you think of
the whitener in Oreo cookies, for example,
doesn't sound like there are major national
security implications necessarily.
But when it comes to industrial espionage,
how frequently are classified technologies
involved?
How frequently are government contractors
or or programs and research involved?
There have been cases involving national security
technologies, but the government, the U.S.
government has basically been arguing that
an attack on our U.S. corporations and an
attack on our economic security is an attack
on national security.
So there's been this kind of expansive reimagining
of what national security means as this has
become a priority.
When you talk about industrial espionage,
is the motivation typically a motivation of
getting an advantage when it comes to the
ability to earn a profit?
I mean, is that national security instances
aside?
Is that mostly what is at issue here, trying
to earn a profit by getting some kind of technology,
technique, product or otherwise an element
of something from another company?
Sure.
Yeah.
China is developing very rapidly or it was
developing, I should say, before the start
of the global pandemic.
And there are a lot of companies who are really
just interested in short term getting ahead
at all costs.
Stealing technology is the most expedient
way to do that.
But, you know, I wanted to draw attention
to whether this is the best use of our resources.
The policies that the Trump administration
put in place led to the deterioration of U.S.
China relations, which is now absolutely critical.
Now we're seeing with the pandemic that cooperation
could be essential to fighting it.
And all of this back and forth over industrial
espionage really led to the decline of of
that relationship.
So not that an eye for an eye is the right
or the wrong thing, but just so that we have
all the information.
How frequently is the US doing the same thing
elsewhere?
The U.S. stance is that we don't spy for the
benefit, specific benefit of our private corporations.
There are some people who take issue with
that who point to small examples of it could've
happened here or there.
But, you know, in general, the US is at a
point in our development where we don't need
to.
There were certainly points in our history
where we did take a lot of technologies in
early America.
There was quite a lot that was stolen from
England, for example.
But China's now at that stage where it is
rapidly developing and where the the US has
a lot of desirable technologies.
I think that the question is, should an ear
of corn be treated like a national security
secret?
Yes.
So let's get into that story.
I mean, describe the story that you tell and
highlight in the book, The Scientist and the
Spy.
So I look at the case of Robert Mom, who was
a Chinese born engineer who was found in an
Iowa cornfield in 2011.
He was initially suspected of trespassing,
but his appearance there ended up setting
off this two year FBI investigation involving
surveillance planes and airport busts and
the use of a FISA warrant, which is intended
to be reserved for extreme national security
threats.
And what was he trying to accomplish in that
cornfield?
Well, it was a Monsanto corn fields.
The company treated the next generation high
hybrid corn that was growing there as trade
secrets.
Robert Moore worked for a Beijing agricultural
company that wanted to steal that corn.
At one point, they actually tried to send
it back to China in microwave popcorn bags.
So they had this kind of harebrained scheme.
And the FBI, meanwhile, decided to track them
over years and bugging their cars, chasing
them across the Midwest.
And so you had this kind of absurd cat and
mouse chase that in the end was a massive
use of taxpayer taxpayer resources.
Yes.
So there's there's so much to talk about with
regard to this.
I mean, what you mentioned the question of
is this a good use of FBI resources which
are taxpayer funded?
That's one debate to be had.
The other question is, is this another example
of corporate power and the degree to which
corporations dictate law enforcement priorities,
whether you want to talk about private prisons,
existing influences, the judicial system and
how the judicial system functions?
Should that be the case?
I would argue.
No.
Is that not another underlying story here?
Which is that because of what who Monsanto
is, they have a lot of say in what the FBI
does.
It doesn't work on.
Oh, definitely.
You know, so I retraced Robert most steps,
I retrace the steps of the FBI agent who is
tailing him there.
At one point there were 70 some agents working
on the case of dozens of people and multiple,
multiple states.
Just a massive use of resources.
And, you know, as I was traveling around the
Midwest talking to farmers about this case,
there were many people said to me, look, you
know, Monsanto and Dupont pioneer another
company in this.
In this case, they have massively consolidated
over the past few years.
They to the point where the price of seed
has gone up for many, many farmers.
And when you look at what the impediments
to innovation in agriculture are, that corporate
consolidation is is a very big one.
Now, on the other side of this, you know,
it's very easy to say, hey, listen, there's
intellectual property here and the intellectual
property is being violated or threatened.
You've got a guy standing in a cornfield.
It's sort of pretty cut and dry.
Aside from whether the FBI should be involved
there, only local police or whatever, that's
one question.
But on the other side of that is it may be
too easy to get intellectual property protection
for things that one could debate whether they
should or should not be subject to that level
of protection from government, intellectual
property infrastructure in the sense that,
you know, when we talk about what can you
trademark, what can you patent, et cetera.
That's another side to this story.
That is, you know, I do think there is a big
a big place for IP protection.
You know, I'm a writer.
I believe that my my work should be protected.
I don't want people out there pirating my
book.
Same with my head had absolutely agree.
On the other hand, you know, when you look
at what should be done to protect innovation
in this country, there's also a big role for
antitrust enforcement.
And that's something that has really taken
a backseat to other priorities in the past
few years.
But even in the Obama years, there were several
big antitrust actions that fell apart.
And one of them involves Monsanto.
So even as the Justice Department was bringing
this case on basically on behalf of Monsanto,
there was an antitrust inquiry explored by
another arm of the department that then fell
apart.
Well, that seems to be if you zoom out, that's
the trend, right.
Which is when it comes to allowing intellectual
property protection, it by and large benefits
large corporations over small individuals.
And we see that, you know, in MySpace, we
see it on platforms like YouTube and others
where the benefit of the doubt by default
goes to the large media company and not the
small producer, et cetera.
You bring up antitrust, which is an opportunity
to regulate and control some of these large
corporations.
But again, there it's not nearly enough used,
as you're sort of pointing out.
So is that the overarching story or what is
really the overarching story here when it
comes to industrial espionage in your mind?
Well, ultimately, I was drawn to this story
because it was such a good story, had all
these twists and turns and these interesting
characters, nobody was really for we all good
or all bad.
And just very kind of complex.
And I saw that I could structure it like a
thriller.
But at the same time, it also tapped into
all these other themes of corporate control,
the expansion of what constitutes national
security, of the FBI, turning itself from
a law enforcement agency into a counterintelligence
agency, which has also played a big role in
in the expansion of what constitutes an investigation.
And and so this by looking at this one small
case, I could get all these other issues.
So if we zoom out from this case a little
bit, can you give us some other types of industrial
espionage that maybe are less obvious than
than the case?
We're talking about corn and Monsanto seeds
and some of those others that are under that
umbrella.
What else is included under this umbrella
of industrial espionage more broadly?
Oh, pharmaceuticals.
The insulation that's used in walls.
Any lot of industrial compounds and chemicals.
And, you know, basically, if you look at the
major corporations in America and what they're
manufacturing, many of those products have
been the subject of these industrial espionage.
Keep them factions.
This stuff can be life and death in some cases.
Right.
I mean, now when we're talking about a ninety
five masks and masks that are at issue when
it comes to health care workers that are treating
corona virus patients.
And, you know, you start hearing about rotten
masks or faulty masks, masks that are called
and ninety five, but aren't really.
I mean, this is all wrapped up with some of
this intellectual property is it not.
Right.
Well that yeah.
Counterfeiting is a big issue as well.
And I've just been looking into that for another
story.
Certainly a big concern and that is really
about the concern over PPE and masks and where
they're coming from.
That's really about global supply chain issues.
And that's certainly been complicated by the
trade war that Trump has started with China.
And, you know, also just by the general decline
in U.S. China relations.
So over the past few weeks, things have really
reached a new low with China at precisely
at the moment when we need we most need to
be cooperating on this issue.
So last thing I want to touch on is as far
as the trade war and the inclusion of, again,
trying to stop Chinese spying and theft of
intellectual property.
Donald Trump very loudly said that China's
doing this.
He said the trade agreed that not trade agreement,
but the trade, the tariffs and the larger
package that he put in place was going to
solve that.
And he even recently offhandedly said that
this is something that he has now fixed through
his policy.
What's the truth of that is that is the policy
that Trump put in place, including tariffs
actually solving this issue.
It certainly hasn't.
It certainly hasn't helped us in terms of
sourcing medical supplies from China because
there are still some tariffs in place, but
just more generally, the.
He has pushed us away from China.
Things were already bad when he came into
office.
But by using phrases like Chinese virus and
then kind of perpetually pointing fingers,
encouraging China to do the same, which they
have.
We've reached a really a new low point.
And in u.s.-china relations, what would be
a policy that would actually work constructively
to resolve the issue of industrial espionage
between the U.S. and China?
Well, whatever we do, we need to put in place
a policy that doesn't make researchers feel
targeted.
So that's another piece of the puzzle, is
that there is this perception among many Chinese,
American and Chinese scientists they are being
singled out because of their ethnicity and
some of them maybe have committed infractions.
But there are also cases where people have
been arrested who turned out to be innocent.
And so that's ultimately detrimental to the
U.S. innovation infrastructure.
If we drive out a lot of the research force
and we're seeing that now as we try to develop
vaccines and try to develop treatments for
COBA 19, that many of the people who could
be working on this are now back in China because
they've been driven out by overzealous investigations.
We've been speaking with Mara Visting Doll,
who is the former China correspondent for
science and also author of the book The Scientist
and the Spy A True Story of China, the FBI,
an Industrial Espionage.
Mara, so great having you on.
I really appreciate your time.
Thank you again.